[Music]
I didn't really know how money worked it
was well as things where I just thought
they would kind of come natural I was
just watching my mom she liked all types
of credit cards so I thought that was
the right way to go it's the thing that
everybody should know how to do and
there's just this assumption that you
just automatically learned that when you
go to school but that's not true we
spent over a hundred thousand dollars
per kid to educate them now at the end
of the day if 78% of them are living
paycheck to paycheck
what is that return on investment and it
takes you right back to we've never
taught it I mean what results do we
expect to get
[Music]
the earlier that we can get to them and
give them the basic principles of how
money works and more they are preparing
themselves to make better decisions this
class really is the whole foundation of
your financial future and if you don't
take this class and you're missing out
on something really important that you
can't just learn on your own I believe
this is the most important class that
every student in high school should be
taking and every high school should be
offering I absolutely felt empowered
after taking this class I felt like I
had more knowledge than most people my
age and after going out into the adult
workforce I realized that I had more
financial knowledge than most other
adults the value that this class brought
to me is it's forever changing my life
and my family's life the Foundation's
course has allowed me to make a
difference that I always dreamed about
being a teacher I don't want to leave
the classroom financial education is one
of the things we are very proud of being
able to offer to our community
sponsoring the Foundation's
in personal finance curriculum is
providing an opportunity for students at
all levels without our sponsor they
would not have had this curriculum they
would not have had the opportunity for
this life-changing program that we offer
[Music]